[Applause]
it's been a minute you want to hear a
minut ago yeah and actually it was
during Co remember that we had the it
was like a SciFi yeah the screens yeah
when I talk to everybody via screen yeah
exactly I like you physically in person
more absolutely how are thank you yeah
so wait it's New Year's now so what what
what do youall do in Venezuela do you
have any like special things yall do um
in Venezuela many uh there is there is
one that I used to do when I was a kid
yeah and it really really paid off you
you go around I mean when the clock hits
12 you hog everybody and then you take a
suitcase and go around the block running
around the block and that will give you
a lot of travels you know um during the
year so I did it a lot when I was a kid
and now I'm traveling all the time
you're traveling all the time it works
it pays off do it there's something with
grapes as well right cuz I think they do
the same thing in Mexico cuz I've done I
was in Mexico once and they were like
they all and there are grapes at the
table and I think they do the same thing
the same thing so so each each it's 12
grapes for for the months of the year
and it's 12 yeah it's 12 months right
yeah of course they 12 months yeah
exactly so so so it's 12 wishes yeah and
then right before the clock hits 12 then
you have to eat them yes and make a wish
for each grape yeah yeah I thought
whenever I was doing I heard someone in
because I was drinking tequila and I
heard them say you have to eat it in the
first minute but I feel it's actually
have to eat them each minute like the
first 12 minutes so I was like just just
I wanted my wishes to come true I wish
just like you I always do it I always do
it in the 12 seconds before yeah I did
it I yeah somebody was like no no no it
was like one a minute and I was like no
I didn't hear that anyway I got my
wishes though so there you
[Music]
go
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home